par le fondateur et ancien pdg d'amazon
si on peut avoir les images en direct
depuis le texas tout va décoller sept
vaisseaux voilà on voit les véhicules
qui transportent l'équipage se diriger
vers le pas de tir c'est un deuxième vol
qui a lieu moins de trois mois après le
vol inaugural du 20 juillet dernier que
vous aviez pu suivre également sur
figaro live en direct et dans lequel
jeff bezos lui même avait pris place aux
côtés de son frère marc on s'en souvient
d'une aviatrice de 82 ans ou ali funk et
d'un jeune de 18 ans qui se nommait
olivier dabène cette fois ci jeff bezos
a choisi de faire s'envoler dans le
cosmos un symbole un héros de science
fiction le fameux capitaine kirk de la
série culte star strek c'est en effet
l'acteur canadien william shatner qui
prendra place dans la capsule new
shepard dans quelques minutes pour un
vol habité de dix minutes seulement et
oui c'est assez court aux côtés de trois
autres passagers alors est ce que vous
aimeriez vous aussi prendre place dans
ce type de vaisseau pour aller observer
la courbure de la terre trouvez vous que
ce type de mythes des deux missions fait
inventer fait avancer la science ou
pensez-vous au contraire que ce type de
projet sont coûteux voire scandaleux et
bien faites nous part de vos
commentaires de vos réactions de votre
question sur le chat du figaro sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre chaîne youtube
notre invité se fera un plaisir de vous
répondre notre invité que je salut
bonjour tristan veille merci d'être en
direct avec nous on va commenter
ensemble ce vol qui a pris déjà 45
minutes de retard 39 minutes non 45
minutes de retard il était censé
décoller à 15 heures on est à 15h52 donc
un peu de retard pour ce vol je dis une
bêtise excusez moi je corrige il était
censé décoller à 15h30 et nous sommes à
15h52 donc un peu de retard c'est pour
ça que les véhicules se dirigent
seulement maintenant vers le pas de tir
je rappelle simplement pour nos
internautes que vous êtes chef adjoint
du service sciences et médecine du
figaro et on sait à quel point les
questions qui concernent le cosmos et
l'espace vous passionne on le voit sur
ces images donc c'est l'inoubliable kirk
capitaine kirk de la série star trek
l'acteur william shatner qui se dirige
lentement mais sûrement vers
7 9 est ce vaisseau sur le pas de tir
pour vivre un vol suborbital qui est
permis donc par jeff bezos ce via sa
société blue origin on imagine triste
avec qu'invité l'un des plus célèbres
voyageurs spatiaux de science fiction
n'est pas un geste innocent est ce qu'il
ya pas du côté de jeff bezos le besoin
de maintenir l'intérêt du public pour
pour ce type de mission dans cette
course au tourisme spatial engagé entre
plusieurs entreprises du secteur depuis
quelques mois maintenant voici c'est
clairement un gros coup de com blue
origin est dans une situation un peu
délicate
pris entre des revers successifs avec la
nasa notamment la non sélection de son
intérieur lunaire au profit de space x
qui a été un petit coup de tonnerre
voilà s'était engagé dans la tanière
depuis bien plus longtemps il s'est fait
voler
la vedette au dernier moment par elon
musk et son starship sont immenses
vaisseaux dont j'espère qu'on pourra
assister un lancement peut-être d'ici la
fin de l'année ou en début d'année
prochaine est pris aussi dans des dans
un
semi scandale en ce moment avec un site
et blue origin qui est accusé de sexisme
de harcèlement de effectivement il ya
cette polémique depuis quelques jours
quelques jours donc
de l'entreprise je crois oui c'est ça
c'est les circonstances sont pas
extrêmement clair mais voyez des
rapports qui ont filtré dans la presse
les questions de politique d'entreprise
assez
assez voile assez
négative ouais notamment sur le
l'interdiction de communiquer des
employés etc sa voix l'équipage en ce
moment est un peu les rumeurs qui
avaient jusqu'à présent qui était que
ben l'origine d'une société patras et
opaque et et dont l'ambiance était pas
forcément au beau fixe donc ça vient lee
alimenter un peu tout ça donc oui c'est
sûr que le coup de com là et
ça intervient impôts meilleurs moments
au mauvais moment où médias non aux
basques aime toujours là du coup on voit
qu'on parle de blue origin partout
aujourd'hui
plus pour ce vol là que pour ce rapport
diane trois jours donc voulait dire que
cette cette actualité qu'on est en
france yves maintenant pourrait évacuer
et mettre un peu de côté cette polémique
qui concerne l'entreprise blue ridge on
mettre de côté je ne sais pas je sais
pas mais en tout cas c'est sûr que c'est
pas pour ça que ça a été fait ça avait
été prévue bien avant cela
mais bon c'est peut-être permettre de
détourner un peu
l'attention et après concernant le futur
du des vols touristiques et des holdings
ou jean on n'a pas beaucoup de détails
l'entreprise a très peu communiqué sur
le carnet de commandes elles assurent
que les candidats sont nombreux voilà il
faut les croire pour l'instant sur
parole si vous nous rejoignez maintenant
en direct et sur figaro live et notre
chaîne youtube les biens vous n'hésitez
pas à nous faire part de vos
commentaires et vos questions en rapport
avec ce décollage que nous attendons de
cette capsule ce vaisseau new shepard de
la société blue origin fondée par jeff
bezos le fondateur et ex pdg d'amazon
qui avait pris par lui sur ce premier
vol daté du mois de juillet et
maintenant c'est le deuxième vol est
cette fois ci c'est non plus lui la
vedette de ce vol là mais c'est le
capitaine kirk william shatner le
comédien phare de la série star trek qui
a fait les beaux jours de la télévision
à partir des années 60 et que tout le
monde a pu un moment donné on le voit
sur cette image william shatner dans la
combinaison
officielle de ce vol n/s 18 et
l'équipage qui l'accompagnent on va les
sites est justement la femme que vous
voyez à l'image audrey powers qui est la
vice-présidente des missions et des
opérations aériennes chez blue origin à
ses côtés il y a un garçon qui s'appelle
chris bowen qui est cofondateur de la
société d'observation de la terre
planète labs et puis un autre homme glen
drive qui travaille lui chez dassault
systems une entreprise qui est plus tôt
familière de notre entreprise le figaro
voilà vous les voyez tous les quatre on
peut le dire de nouveau tristan ce ne
sont pas des astronautes
professionnels ce ne sont pas des
habitués des vols suborbitaux ou
spatiaux
certains internautes quand je préparais
cette émission se moquait un petit peu
de la mention équipages pour citer et
parler de ces quatre personnes il était
plutôt dans la dans la comparaison avec
de simples voyageurs des passagers qui
prennent un ticket pour aller faire un
tour là oh oui après c'est juste des le
vocabulaire de l'aéronautique a beaucoup
repris à celui justement du du bateau
voilà comment sont un bateau ont peu
fait partie un équipage donc ça me ça me
choque pas plus que ça c'est vrai que
leur rôle dans le pilotage de la capsule
est très limité pour ne pas dire nulles
le le rôle se limite à avoir appris des
procédures d'urgence pour notamment
quitté la capsule avant le décollage ce
genre de choses tout le vol ensuite géré
de manière automatique donc
effectivement c'est pas
c'est pas un équipage au sens très actif
du terme c'est plutôt des touristes
spatiaux après c'est un peu pour le
folklore un des apps l'astronaute
et des pires varie il ya certaines
définitions qui font de nastran
seulement celui qui a bouclé une
révolution autour de la terre
auquel cas il y aurait seulement les
passagers de space x
il ya un ou deux mois qui entre dans
cette catégorie a précédé les basses et
futile je trouve l'important c'est de
voir la terre depuis l'espace je pense
que
voilà selon les quelques minutes passées
passé justement à 100km qu'on peut voir
la courbure de la terre le noir de
l'espace et le bleu du ciel en dessous
assez ses pieds d'une certaine manière
ce sont des moments assez assez assez
magique les premiers passagers ont tous
rapporté avoir une expérience assez
extraordinaire
voilà c'est ça c'est ça
l'essentiel je pense alors que vous
voyez sur ces images diffusées par
l'intermédiaire de l'entreprise blue
origin
et donc comme je le disais fondée par
jeff bezos sondés voient des images
tournées depuis donc le pas de tir situé
au texas à van horne aux etats unis
c'est le matin là bas il est 9h du matin
maintenant
donc un décalage assez important avec
avec nous à paris c'était un décollage
qui était prévu initialement à 15h30
pour une durée de vol de très courtes
dix minutes décalé maintenant à 16h36 on
en croit le compteur c'est bien ça
triste en vrai je le lis bien ce
compteur quand on nous indique times
trente et une minutes et 14 et 12
secondes maintenant saisie des comptes
avant le décollage lisez super v à
savoir juste que si si le décompte en
eau s'arrête pour une raison ou une
autre ça peut arriver
séquence de lancement le décompte soit
arrêté pour une raison ou une autre un
capteur unis une petite alarme il ya en
dessous un 2e 2e chronomètre qui
apparaît avec un h on dit que le
lancement et en roll dont le lancement
est sur pause et il peut reprendre la
chronologie pour reprendre n'importe
quel moment s'est passé tout à l'heure
il le lancement avec une demi heure de
retard à la base puis une demi heure est
déplacé en soldes à 45 minutes 45
minutes c'est le moment où les passagers
doivent quitter en faite le
le centre pour rejoindre le vaisseau
donc je sais pas exactement quelle est
la raison qui a fait qu'ils sont partis
ces voix là avec de retard là on voit
qu'ils se sont installés dans une cabine
dans lesquelles ils finissent de se
préparer alors on est un peu étonné
parce que il devait y avoir quatre
passagers en combinaison il y en a 5
j'ai l'impression que jeff bezos
s'accompagne finalement l'équipage
j'ai l'impression que c'est lui qui est
assis en bas à gauche et qui se lève là
cet instant effectivement il n'a pas les
mêmes chaussures que l'équipage qui est
censée monter à bord du vaisseau
c'est bien lui 1 c'est bien oui c'est
bien des p o skréla vrp de luxe un peu
aujourd'hui il a fait le celui qui
conduisait les qui conduisaient des
passagers jusqu'au vaisseau il
rassemblement les accompagner à la
capsule
voilà moi c'est d
imaginer des enjeux d'image encore une
fois c'est la communication je crois pas
qu'ils montent à bord en revanche mon
cas c'était pas prévu il était prévu
qu'ils soient qu'ils les accompagnent
mais pas que pas qu'ils montent à bord
de la capsule pour effectuer ce qu'on
peut on peut considérer aujourd'hui que
que cet équipage là et clients des jeff
bezos sont pas encore ce sont des deux
qui son client est
il ya deux clients william shatner lui
invité et il ya une passagère qui est
donc une vision cramaille
exactement le cas il ya deux passagers
payants et même gennart qui pourrait
devenir voilà 90 ans
alors 90 ans effectivement william
shatner
là derrière chris boyes and co fondateur
de la société d'observation de la terre
planète labs précédé par blaise van
driessche ce que je disais travail chez
dassault systèmes et enfin derrière
william shatner cette femme qui
travaille donc blue origin les vice
présidentes des missions et des
opérations aériennes audrey powers est
celui qui ferme la marche
de l'équipage en uniforme et bien c'est
jeff bezos celui même qui est assez fine
jusqu'au bout
cet équipage de quatre personnes 90 ans
pour un membre d'équipage d'une d'un
vaisseau qui mine de rien va être assez
secoué qui va sur be et subir donc des
turbulences probablement avec le stress
qui incombe à ce type de nos missions
malgré tout est-ce que c'est pas un peu
risqué ben je présume après sans avoir
de certitude mais je présume que
messieurs shatner a fait un bilan
cardiaque avant d'aller au même titre
que on le fait avant un saut en
parachute par exemple pour vérifier que
le coeur effectivement
solide c'est pas tant la poussée qui est
gênante et ils vont prendre 3g mais
c'est comme une attraction de fête
foraine
mais dans une fête foraine le le risque
que jamais liée à
à laon madero
l effort physique qui est pratiqué mais
vraiment à la
montée du coeur
en régime qui est lié à la peur au
stress à l' angoisse et c'est donc c'est
plus ça con con qu'on vérifie donc le
meilleur moyen de s'en prémunir c'est de
faire un test d'effort où on en bon fait
emballer son coeur son besoin d'efforts
physiques et on vérifie que le coeur se
comportent correctement jusqu'au qui se
comporte correctement pendant un effort
physique a pas de raison particulière
que sous l'effet d'un stress qui fait
monter là qui fait monter le coeur en
régime on ait de problème
voilà après quatre vingt dix ans avec
c'est un agent général il
[Musique]
deviendrait le plus âgé si ça décolle
à avoir pour l'instant à belle-île
décrocher et reprendraient leurs corps à
web iphone qu'il aurait des tenues très
b avant la présente passagère de la
notion du 20 juillet dernier c'était la
première mission de sony prépare avec
donc wali funk est âgé de 82 ans puis à
ses côtés il y avait le plus jeune
des astronautes on va dire qu'il lui
avait 18 ans olivier oliver diamond
regarder son record des couloirs oui
c'est pas tout de suite que j'imagine y
aura un enfant qui aurait monté à bord
d'un tel engin voilà on voit où william
shatner qui s'engouffrent dans cette
capsule
il est prévu que le que la porte se
refermer 24 minutes avant le décollage
donc une en deux minutes après dans les
dans les temps capsule vitréens pour
permettre on voit jeff bezos cela qui
serre la main de d'audrey powers donc
travail pour grégory jean
présidente des missions et des
opérations aériennes chez blue origin
donc une capsule vitré je le disais qui
permettra à chacun des quatre passagers
d'observer au mieux la courbure de la
terre
100 km d'altitude on est à une frontière
je lisais une frontière fils c'était un
nom particulier
de karmann la ligne de kerman exactement
mais des noms d'un ingénieur de la nasa
des années je crois 50 60 qui a théorisé
cette limite c'est il avait calculé
plutôt à 83 km je crois soit environ 50
miles était prêt le
la hauteur à laquelle on estime que les
forces et rené micon être négligeable
donc où en gros un avion peut plus
vraiment voler correctement
c'est rhétorique n ya pas de raison
particulière ya pas de évidemment de
lignes très exact qui définissent la fin
de l'atmosphère l'atmosphère se
raréfient progressivement on peut
retrouver des habitudes des parties doit
se faire à des milliers de kilomètres
donc c'est vraiment une ligne souvent
théorique à partir de les astros tu me
racontes qu'en gros quand commence à
dépasser 70 km on voit là le noir au
dessus de sa tête et en dessous le le
bleu du ciel en plein jour et que voilà
c'est ça qui
définit et donc voilà qu'on soit 85 km
n'observe très bien ce phénomène là plus
on est haut plus on voit loin
donc on l'horizon se
seraient repoussés plus loin je crois
que pour la capsule blue origin environ
6,6 ont décollé après du milieu de la
france on verrait à peu près toutes les
cotes
toutes les côtes du pays quoi c'est ça
vous donne un ordre de grandeur c'est
pas exactement ça près 400 à 4 5 km je
crois de de porter de on est beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins où on va dire que
la spatiale la station spatiale
internationale où se trouvent les images
qu'on voit souvent de de l'espace sont
prises depuis y est c'est ce qui à 400
km dont quatre fois plus haut c'est pas
non plus
beaucoup plus haut que la différence en
terme de ressenti et de sensations et
pas très dit très très différentes entre
100 et 400 km d'après les astronautes
encore une fois j'y suis pas allé mais
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'il raconte
la grosse différence c'est le temps
qu'on y passe quoi là c'est vrai que ça
va être quand ces trois quatre minutes
d'un pesanteur a regardé par le hublot
j'avais été assez frappé lors du premier
vol on a vu des images ensuite
dans la capsule
ils ont en fait passé pas mal de temps à
jouer avec l'un de la pesanteur ils vont
peut-être en apesanteur un moment donné
ça chez ils vont pouvoir alors on peut
être mais vont pouvoir ressentir les
effets de la pesanteur ya deux minutes
mais là mais c'est un phénomène de chute
libre en fait c'est juste on peut le
ressentir dans des vols 0 j'ai
brassé d'espoir c'est effectivement pour
pour se laisser aller et volé un peu
comme on l'a vu avec avec richard
branson à bord de son vaisseau virgin
galactic qui vont pouvoir le faire dans
cette capsule là je veux le faire sans
problème je pense qu'il ya quand même un
peu d espaces
non non c'est juste que voilà cc c'est
un peu dommage parce que c'est cette
sensation d'apesanteur même si elle peut
paraître
très étonnante on l'a on peut la vivre
dans des avions il ya plein d'avion qui
font des voix le zéro j'ai donc on peut
vivre sa part séquence de 20 40 secondes
de l'impesanteur la la spécificité
vraiment de ses vols c'est de voir
l'espace quoi et de voir la courbure de
la terre et j'étais un peu surpris de ne
pas les voir plus haut et blu en fait
parce que c'est ça vraiment qui est
fantastique à la sensation d'apesanteur
on n'a pas vraiment besoin de faire des
galipettes dans ces débats le sait c'est
rigolo mais
mais en fait là ce qu'il faut à mon sens
est vraiment resté collé aux îles de lau
on sent avec son corps
et pas besoin de jouer en fait on se
sens emplois et donc je pense que la
combinaison de se sentir sans poids et
de regarder par la fenêtre la terre en
dessous nous etc je pensais ça le
l'aspect vraiment très particulier cet
expert line max de l'expérience joué
avec des balles de ping pong
qui flotte dans l'air franchement c'est
bon je me dis c'est un peu passé à côté
du sein peuvent passer à côté de la du
côté merveilleux quoi parce que ça c'est
des vols des vols zéro g j'ai pas dire
que c'est c'est pas cher et moi
n'importe qui peut sans payer pour
sauver l'euro oui 5000 euros en fait un
vol zéro-g ont fait 18 parabole et on
passe en tout dix minutes en apesanteur
si vous voulez le faire on peut le faire
en france à bordeaux ça se fait aux
états unis à des compagnies des
entreprises qui le font également c'est
pas tant pour la présente c'est ce que
vous dites c'est essentiellement pour
voir la courbure de la terre de ses yeux
et vivre un peu dans les 400
centrifugeuses ces techniques thomas
thomas pesquet en quelque sorte même si
lui c'est pas trois minutes qui voit la
courbure c'est des mois et des mois où
il a vu d'abord au moment du décollage
et puis après il est vraiment au dessus
d'eux bien ce qu'ils ont des tout petits
hublots dans l'est dans les navettes
dans les navettes justement qui permet
d'aller les capsules qui permet d'aller
il ya cesse l'ailé gauche en tout petit
donc ils le voient ils disent que c'est
quelque chose de fantastique l'asra
qu'ils ont des hublots bien plus
imposant que la vue doit être
particulièrement spectaculaire
après flotter dans l'espace sur de
longues périodes ça c'est une expérience
qui doit être
qui est vraiment intéressant de
l'entente entre 30 secondes et 3 minutes
suis pas certain qu'ils soient majeurs
comme différence sûr qu'être astronautes
est passé six mois en apesanteur c1
c'est encore autre chose c'est tout à
fait autre chose mais la voilà pour un
vol de trois quatre minutes franchement
il faut vraiment profiter pour je pense
pour rester collé au hublot et regarder
ce qui se passe dehors stressé en
dommage de se priver des envies de ce
spectacle les coûts et
unique à part regarder des vidéos sur
oui et c'est ce que le voir de ses yeux
c'est vraiment autre chose merci à tous
coeurs agi les hadjs 1974 merci
également à un habitué rome 37 91 qui
nous suit sur le chat du figaro vous
êtes nombreux à nous faire part de vos
commentaires et vos questions beaucoup
de commentaires sur
l'utilité la légitimité
d'un vol comme celui ci qui favorise
effectivement un tourisme qui est pour
l'instant réservé à des personnes
fortunées des milliardaires ou des gens
capacité des entreprises en capacité de
payer ce type de vol
ça une utilité particulière d'aller
voler d'aller voir la courbure de la
terre
où ça reste un loisir
destiné à une élite quelle est l'utilité
de faire du jet-ski quelle est l'utilité
d'aller en vacances
faire des safaris quelle est l'utilité
de prendre l'avion pour les ce soit
c'est tout dépend de ce qu'on appelle
l'utilité mais comme vous quand on lit
la le commentaire de juillet 1974
combien de vies sauvées sur terre avec
l'argent dépensé pour ces vols spatiaux
inutile bien de combien d'enfants
seraient de la famille non les budgets
de larmes et un jeu face à ses pieds ça
me paraît vraiment des
débats un petit viau et sans
grand intérêt que l'argent qui est
investi dans dans ce programme là il
reprend le moindre pet et investement
autre chose tu as d'autres gens comme
comme vives qui va investir sa fondation
dont beaucoup d'argent sa fondation pour
essayer de résoudre des problèmes de
développement on l'accusera aussi de
faire ça pour son image et donc du coup
de le faire pour de mauvaises raisons
donc
je trouve que c'est un faux débat quoi
c'est des sommes
beaucoup moins importante que ce qu'on
imagine si les bons c'est peut-être
quelques milliards mais c'est très très
peu encore il le budget de
fonctionnement des armées américaines
sur une année c'est mille fois plus
élevé donc c'est relativement
anecdotique moi je pense qu'après cédé
pour l'instant cette fin servant des
passionnés qui vont c'est la nana
[Musique]
il ya un des passagers qui est un pilote
civil enfin vous pensez à au fondateur
de la société observation de la terre
planète non l'autre
chez dassault systèmes patron de métiers
d'art medidata qui a été racheté par de
ce système et siège du coucher c'est mon
fond peu importe c'est un détail mais le
voilà c'est un passionné planète lable
voilà c'est un ancien ingénieur de la
nasa qui a fondé une compagnie
d'observation de la terre qui vend des
solutions avec des petits satellites
voilà qui bon qui permet de faire plein
de choses
c'est pas
je sais pas comment dire c'est pas une
attraction c'est pas des gens qui vont
faire ça comme ils vont
je peux aller à space mountain à
disneyland il ya qu'il met quand même
leur vie en jeu une fusée ça reste une
fusée ci est ce qu'on peut considérer
que ça fait avancer la science ce type
de vol est ce que ça fait avancer la
science et la science mais comme le
touriste ne fait pas ventilation se dire
comme des gens qui font le vendée globe
font pas avancer la science et des
grands aventuriers c'est une aventure
humaine incroyable et après bon ils
peuvent toujours s'adjoindre quelques
petites expériences pour certains
bateaux mais c'est c'est pas l'objectif
quoi du vendée globe c2c pas le alors
les sciences je vous interromps c'est
jeff bezos celui même qui qui ferment
définitivement
avant ce vol la capsule nous shepard
de blue origin jeff bezos ce donc que je
vous le rappelle l'ancien pdg d'amazon
mais fondateur de amazon qui a donc ré
blue origin en 2000 pour faire voler ils
sont des passagers comme aujourd'hui et
comme au mois de juillet dernier
aujourd'hui c'est pas jeff bezos ce qui
montre d'abord de cette capsule mais
c'est la petite le capitaine kirk et
qu'on a tous ceux connus quand on était
plus ou moins jeunes de la série star
trek william shatner l'acteur canadien
81 10 ans et désormais à bord de cette
capsule qui devrait s'envoler d'ici
quinze minutes et 39 secondes si on en
croit le décompte
on va re le juste revenir sur sur un
aspect pratique on l'a vu tout à l'heure
quand cet équipage est arrivé dans ses
combinaisons bleues toutes les missions
spatiales
ont toujours une combinaison
univ uniforme et commune à l'ensemble
des passagers il ya certains internautes
qui racontait qui s'interrogeait
cependant pendant les heures qui
précèdent ce décollage sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui estimé que l on aurait
plutôt dû être rouge ces combinaisons
aujourd'hui en hommage justement à star
trek et l'équipage de star trek léo date
de cet aspect là il y avait des
questions concernant l'utilité de ces
combinaisons pourquoi d'ailleurs on fait
porter une combinaison aux passagers et
aux membres d'équipage d'une mission
comme celle ci est est-ce qu'elles ont
une quelconque utilité en particulier
pour l'heure pour les protéger en cas de
d'incidents en l'occurrence je suis pas
certain que ces combinaisons et beaucoup
d'intérêt pour les astronautes de métier
c'est des combinaisons qui vont être qui
va les protéger un peu du feu les bottes
sont notamment étanche en cas de
problème ils ont un scaphandre qui leur
permet de respirer là y'a rien de tout
ça le vol est trop court ya pas vraiment
de risque d'avoir besoin de
dépressurisation de la cabine
pendant le vol 2 min ivoire des masques
à oxygène comme dans un avion
si elle est sûre de problème ils sont
pas dans le iie seront quasiment pas
dans le vide de l'espace très très peu
de temps
après elle fait d'avoir une combinaison
bain en apesanteur voilà c'est c'est la
confidence est quelque chose de pratique
quoi mais c'est en a la même chose pour
les les aviateurs quoi nous en avions
voilà il combat ils ont une combinaison
c'est une forme professionnelle ouais
c'est une comédie dans ses pratiques il
n'y a pas de tee shirts à se prendre une
part c'est ça risque pas de se défaire
la en apesanteur ça risque pas de
flotter on espère se retrouver avec le
pull au dessus de la tête qui me cache
les yeux fermés voilà donc ça que c'est
c'est un peu le sait un peu l'intérêt de
la combinaison mais en l'occurrence je
connais pas bien les combinaisons de
blue origin j'ai pas l'impression
comme ça qu'elle est
qu'elle soit ignifuges et mais c'est
peut-être le cas mais je sais ça paraît
pas comme ça évident et visant si vous
venez nous rejoindre en direct sur
figaro l'arrivée sur notre chaîne
youtube nous vous faisons vivre en
direct le décollage donc de new shepard
blue origin ce deuxième vol initié par
l'ancien pdg d'amazon et fondateur
d'amazon investi à 100% désormais dans
cette entreprise il a même
accompagné lui même les quatre passagers
censé décoller désormais d'ici une
quinzaine de minutes et il a lui-même
également fermé la porte de la capsule
vous êtes déjà nombreux à nous faire
part de vos commentaires de vos
questions on essaie de les relayer je
salue une top coeur boussingault gérard
qui nous précise d'ailleurs un triste
avec les combinaisons sont ignifuges et
donc peut-être at-il eu lui la
confirmation sur sur ce qu'on se disait
il ya quelques secondes on parlait
évidemment il ya quelques minutes des
concurrents de jeff bezos s'est de blue
origin des concurrents qui se sont
positionnés très plus particulièrement
cette année 2021 où de nombreuses
missions ont été médiatisés on va citer
effectivement quelques unes d'entre
elles space x pour ne parler que d'elle
en premier lieu
du célèbre elon musk qui a lancé à son
tour la première mission de tourisme
spatial le 16 septembre dernier
inspiration 4 puis pour quatre passagers
dans ce vaisseau crew drag'on trois
jours dans l'espace c'était la première
mission de l'histoire en envoyer en
orbite que 2 complète novice sans aucun
astronaute professionnels virgin
galactic de richard branson avec richard
branson à bord de son vaisseau le 11
juillet dernier est également très
médiatisé charles bronson qui souhaite
d'ailleurs un début des opérations
régulières en 2022 avec avec son
vaisseau je crois que ça n'est pas très
bien engagé d'ailleurs pour richard
branson parce que l'une des révélations
du new yorker je croise sur un défaut de
trajectoire révélée par par le journal
américain qui aurait pu coûter la vie
des passagers et je crois que la
technologie utilisée par richard branson
avec virgin galactic et si on peut
parler de risque plus risquée que celle
utilisée par jeff bezos ce avec blue
origin
ça semble plus risqué on intercepte le
le procédé un peu plus complexe ça
nécessite des pilotes de combat un
pilotage très fin donc on peut présumer
alors comment là on en sa capsule en
l'air et elle retombe inscriptions
lancer une pomme en l'air j'exagère un
peu ce qu'il faut quand même gérer
toutes là toute la poussée au décollage
c'est une fusée donc c'est comme un
gros réservoir d'explosifs
sur lequel on met une capsule de coups d
un système d un système qui permet
d'évacuer en cas d'explosion la capsule
qui situe au dessus il n'y a pas trop ça
pour lui c'est un signe l'acte i quant
aux problèmes qu'il a eus il n'est pas
très clair de savoir si ça
sami ou non la la vie des passagers en
danger c'est que l'agent n'a pas suivi
la trajectoire qui était qui avait été
déposée auprès de la ffa pour des
questions peut-être devant d'autres
habitudes c'est pas très clair en tout
cas les pilotes
qui sont des pilotes très chevronnés
comme chirurgien et tactiques ont jugé
que ça mettait la trajectoire était pas
du tout dangereuses ou ne présentait
aucun problème particulier ont poursuivi
paul nation et c'est vrai que dans la
perspective de faire venir génial actif
quelque chose de très routinier
et très à normaliser
voilà c'est pas très rassurant pour les
autorités de régulation peut-être et
donc ça ça pourrait peut-être
porter préjudice à virgin galactic
je signale jusque là comme je vous
l'annonçais alors le lancement et sur
old revoilà j'allais vous posez la
question vient de voir apparaître ce h
hall donc il ya une pause de cinq
minutes qui va donc s'additionner aux
non non c'est pas une poussée en fait
c'est le c'est à dire que le lancement
est sûre rôle depuis cinq minutes et où
l'eau que ça fait ça peut durer
éternellement
et quand le quand la pause s'arrêtera en
reprendre à 15 minutes d'accord c'est en
gros le lancement a été arrêté 15 8
avant le décollage y ait dans une
chronologie de lancement il ya un
certain nombre de choses a donc on peut
plus partir désormais sur un chan
décollage à 16h30 comme c'était
initialement 14 sera au maximum dans un
quart d'heure et à chaque seconde où je
vous parle ce sera au maximum
dans un quart d'heure vous pourrez le
suivre évidemment c'est décollage en
direct sur figaro live lefigaro.fr et
sur notre chaîne youtube vous pourrez le
suivre
en direct
en attendant on vous fait vivre
effectivement les préparations les
étapes préparatoires alors là on revoit
ryad bekir en régie nous re montrent les
images du premier vol new chez par blue
origin avec jeff bezos et son chapeau
texan après la réussite de cette
première mission qui a eu lieu au mois
de juillet dernier avec à son bord son
frère marc
l'aviatrice willy funk 82 ans à l'époque
et puis un olivier dimon qui avait 18
ans c'était à juste après l'atterrissage
de la capsule après ce premier vol
suborbital qui s'est déroulée donc le 20
juillet dernier qu'on avait pu vous
faire vivre en direct sur figaro live on
le voit on voyait jeff bezos ce derrière
cette cette petite vitre on était même
inquiet je m'en souviens parce que il
était particulièrement immobile et on se
demandait s'ils n'étaient pas évanouie
non tout se passait bien et tout s'était
bien passé il avait pu atterrir et être
félicités par l'ensemble de ses
collaborateurs donc ça ce sont les
images envoyées en rappel par nom par un
autre régime et
directement blue origin depuis le texas
on revoit les images de la montée des
passagers tout à l'heure un peu plus tôt
ou alors c'est toujours non c'est
toujours le vol le premier vol avec le
chapeau texan de jeff bezos donc du 20
juillet dernier et on devrait s'y voit
là on les voit dans cette salle qu'on a
vu également pour ce deuxième vol
construit en direct sur figaro live
deuxième vol avec quatre passagers à son
bord dont le fameux capitaine kirk de
star trek et donc le comédien canadien
william shatner 90 ans qui est
accompagné de trois autres passagers
dont audrey powers vice-président des
missions et des opérations aériennes
chez blue origin crise ben co fondateur
de la société d'observation de la terre
planète labs et puis viennent devra is
de chez dassault systèmes
ce décollage devrait avoir lieu
maintenant dans une quinzaine de minutes
si tout se passe bien on va revenir sur
les étapes de ce vol et sa durée si ryad
bekir en régie est ce que vous pourriez
nous remontrer les étapes du décollage
blue origin qu'on voyait il ya quelques
secondes entre le moment voilà il ya le
décollage et la séparation la capsule si
vous pouvez me commenté tristan vert
mon premier commentaire le tout ce qui a
l'air très à plat ici se déroule en fait
uniquement à la verticale 1 quasiment
c'est une certes une parabole mais c'est
quasiment
faudra l'image de oui vraiment de d'un
vol le totalement la verticale donc le
le le le vaisseau va décoller ensuite au
bout de quelques minutes il va atteindre
la vitesse de 3700 km heure 3600 km
heure environ
à une altitude
qui doit être the way the sun 15 km même
un peu avant la capsule va se séparer le
moteur est coupé la vso bonne distance à
lancer la capsule se séparent le
propulseur redescend
redescendre et à petit en freinant avec
son ralliement son moteur il est aussi
un des systèmes de freinage passif et il
va venir se poser au sol huit minutes
après le décollage pendant ce temps là
la capsule elle poursuit son envol
il ya trois quatre minutes 2-2 de
microgravité et ensuite la redescendre
ce faisceau parachute avec un petit
système de propulseurs juste avant le
contact avec le sol pour amortir un
petit peu le le choc avec le sol sur le
modèle des des capsules soyouz là on
voit voilà le lieu de
l'atterrissage du propulseur qui est
assez simple il en est beaucoup plus
petit que le falcon nine de donc ça
c'est le prospect 6 revient seul oui
laquelle vous verrez bien voilà quelques
centaines de mètres plus loin je présume
est un kilomètre un peu plus loin sous
parachute à défendre des vues que celles
d'essence ou parachute il ya forcément
ce n'est pas un peu des vents des vents
dominants elles peuvent être plus ou
moins loin le vol l'atterrissage de la
fusée se finira beaucoup plus contrôlés
sur le pas de tir privée s'était fait
sur une dalle de béton les pages sont
redondants donc a priori il y en a un
qui je sais pas si
je pense y en a un qui qui ce qui
fonctionne pas pour une raison ou une
autre c'est pas un problème particulier
de 2,2 parachute de suffire mais
et voilà donc là on voit là la capsule
qui redescend c'est exactement ce qui
devrait se produire le old voilà tient
depuis dix minutes car voilà faut soyez
un peu patients
ce décollage tout là on parlait des
critiques à l'encontre donc dans ce type
de vol considérés comme les prémices et
un tourisme spatial qui devrait se
développer dans les années à venir
gérard sur le chat du figaro.fr figaro
live nous dit sincèrement on peut
critiquer c'est vrai mais vraiment c'est
un événement sympathique surtout avec
william shatner william shatner donc
c'est ce cet acteur canadien qui
incarnait le capitaine kirk dans la
série culte star trek et qui est donc à
bord de cette capsule qui devrait
décoller dans une quinzaine de minutes
mais on n'en sait pas plus pour
l'instant puisqu'il ya eu quand même pas
mal de retard depuis
paris jean comme d'habitude ça sature un
peu frustrant
j'ai pas un jalon là encore zip alors
ayez donc je dois vous avouer que je
n'ai pas le les infos mais en tout cas
tout à l'heure
il y en avait aucune donc je pense que
c'est la même chose là c'est le simple
le silence radio
voilà bon sur les vols de la nasa ou des
agences spatiales européenne les vols
officiels on sait évidemment on entend
le la salle de contrôle
on sait pas toujours ce qui se passe
parce que des fois les ingénieurs
eux-mêmes ne sont pas certains ce qui se
passe mais jamais on a le moins d update
on les entend moins parler faire des
listes de check up
là c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas trop d'idées
de
des raisons pour lesquelles ça a été mis
sur place on a forcément
[Musique]
grave oui mais qu'est ce que beaucoup
nous avons interrogé sur le sérieux ou
la gravité d'un incident qui
justifierait s'est mise en pause
régulière mais en fait ça peut être pour
des simples les anomalies ou des
vérifications de vérification on fait
que tout est bien nominal que tout
voleur je veux vraiment jouer en
l'occurrence enfin cela c'est très
compliqué de donner des informations
quand on n'en a pas je ne peux pas vous
les inventer mais c'est parce que je
vous demande mais ça peut être ça peut
être des choses oui effectivement
relativement
relation anodine et ça peut être des
choses aussi beaucoup plus sérieuse
ça peut aller jusqu'au report du vol ça
arrive qu'on tienne un rôle dans une
heure ou deux que le problème puisse
être résolu ça veut dire qu'en l'état la
on les a vus installé dans la capsule
jeff bezos ça lui même fermé la capsule
de nous chez tarder on pourrait tout
annuler tout pourrait traduire soit leur
demander de sortir de de la capsule et
et rentrer chez eux si depuis c'est un
poème sans aucun problème en plus
cdc des réservoirs d'hydrogène
d'hydrogène et d'oxygène liquide qui a
priori voilà faut après faut vidanger
refaire le plein mais vire seleçao
tempah ya des problèmes pour certains
non diffusés à hydrazine
voilà il faut il faut faire une vidange
la plus complète ne te payer les
réservoirs c'est plus compliqué là c'est
vraiment pas très
problématique de décaler le lancement
s'il le faut voilà pour des vacances et
des problèmes météo on est au courant là
vraiment on n'a aucune information
blue origin voit la partage pas
d'information non plus sur les réseaux
dans le live vidéo montre des images
dévoilent précédent oui c'est vraiment
eu le premier vol 1 comment il disait
tout à l'heure c'est le premier vol
réalisé le 20 juillet dernier avec un
équipage de quatre membres également à
l'époque et il faut le souligner avec
jeff bezos celui même qui avait
participé à cette première mission une
mission qui s'était très bien déroulé
avec un poil de retard mais qui s'était
bien déroulée avec l'atterrissage on l'a
vu tout à l'heure des passagers on
attend ce décollage de cette deuxième
mission à bord de laquelle william
shatner a pris place tout le monde
attend le décollage 2
deux cas du capitaine kirk a eu 90 ans
qui devrait vivre en grandeur nature et
en vrai comme on dit un vol suborbital
dans l'espace on ne sait pas comme vous
disais tristan vrai que que cas quel
moment cette cette mission va pouvoir se
faire pour l'instant c'est plutôt bien
parti mais il ya un retard vous l'avez
dit c'est en pause depuis 14 minutes et
vous devez partir tristan vous avez des
impératifs et des engagements qui vous
attendait et on va vous libérer mais ça
ne vous empêche pas vous qui nous suivez
en direct sur lefigaro.fr de suivre en
direct le décollage de new shepard blue
origin aujourd'hui cette deuxième
mission initiée par jeff bezos ce vous
allez pouvoir le lire le suivre alors
vous le suivrez pas sur youtube mais
vous suivrez sur sur lefigaro.fr on va
prendre le relais sur un autre canal il
suffira pour vous rafraîchir la page
lefigaro.fr et vous aurez donc les
images que vous voyez en ce moment en
direct qui vont continuer sans nous
certes mais vous pourrez vivre en direct
cet évènement sur lefigaro.fr je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis depuis
plus d'une demi heure maintenant sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre chaîne youtube
merci tristan vais pour vos éclairages
et votre passion pour le cosmos et
l'espace on se dit à très vite sur fear
alive très vite